You might get frustrated right now because you haven't eaten and your blood
sugar's low,
but I'm going to be,
I'm going to use the Echo Charles approach of a,
that's weakness,
right?
It's weakness for me to be getting angry.
It's weak for me to be complaining because I'm on the tail end of a 72 hour
fast.
That's just weakness.
Not going to complain.
What are you talking about?
You don't need to eat for 30 days.
People can go 30 days without eating.
For my daughter,
when she was cutting weight for wrestling this past season and she would say
that,
she'd say,
you know,
I'd be getting,
she said,
you know,
dad,
I would get really hungry and then I just think people can live for 30 days
without eating.
I think I can make it through the next eight hours.
Come on.
It's not that big of a deal.
There's no reason to get hangry.
That's just an excuse.
Don't do it.
Carry on with your airborne self.
You know how
I said this before,
there's a difference between how you feel and then how you behave.
You know?
True.
You can get hangry on the inside,
but once you start be behaving like you did too,
man,
get angry on the inside
trading places.
Those are really good.
Like that.
Very good.
Yo.
Actually now that I think about it,
when I was doing deployments after it,
back in the day in the 90s we watched,
we,
there was nothing to do on a ship.
We didn't have an internet.
No one wrote US letters.
No one cared about us.
It was no.
So all we did was play spades and watch movies and we'll movies we watched were
on videotape because this is barker and j and before cds,
before Netflix you had video tape and we had a crate full of videos.
And so we were watching the same,
you know,
cheesy movies over and over and over again.
Probably trading places was one of them.
So if you go on it,
if you were to go back further in the movies,
you're not cause cause what am I,
five years older than you?
Yeah,
fuck sick.
Five or six years.
Yeah.
So I'm just five or six years ahead of you on movies.
So there's a whole bunch of cheesy movies that I actually know about that you
might not know about.
Yeah.
And occasionally we're getting an overlap.
Trade places,
polices iconic anywhere you the man.
Oh yeah.
But hangry,
right?
Karate man bleed on the inside.
Hang.
I liked that word hangry,
by the way.
That's
plenty.
But that implies that you're kind of like,
oh,
I'm hangry.
You know?
Like,
like you're expressing yourself,
you know,
don't express yourself.
Yeah.
Your emotions and keep it on the,
and act like a winner.
You fee,
you can feel like a loser on the inside.
You can feel hangry,
but act like don't act like that whole liver.
Other people see you be all static like that.
Like,
Oh yeah,
I haven't eaten in four days.
Whatever you,
you know what?
No.
Do you hear this joke?
You know what I mean?
Just,
hey,
I haven't eaten in six days.
No big deal.
I'm going to go train Jujitsu.
What are you doing?
Yep.
So yeah.
Oh,
what are you doing?
Sitting around being weak.
Go Dude.
I'll be over here doing something else.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Separate.
Separate your feeling and your behavior and typically when it's the end,
you know,
you even have a word for it crept up on you and I had no control over it.
No,
you,
you identified it,
gave it a name,
everything.
And if,
I mean,
if my experience serves me a lot of times when people say like,
Oh,
I have,
I get hangry or um,
pms scene or I'm whatever,
it's to explain their common behavior.
Meaning they just let it go.
They embrace it.
That's how,
that's how it is for them kind of thing.
Please forgive me.
I'm hangry.
Yeah,
yeah.
I get like that sometimes.
What are you talking about?
And you just let it go,
you know,
be like that on the inside.
Be Good on the outside.
Separate the feelings versus behavior.
Next question.
Stifle your emotions inside.
You know,
they say like if you get emotions,
you've got to like let it out,
punch a pillow or whatever.
Yeah.
I guess as it turns out,
that's not true because if you intern,
you know how you say stifle,
oh,
well the reason I kind of say that with sarcasm is because I think that the,
for instance,
yeah.
You like you're saying people these days,
they say,
Oh,
you know,
you've got to let your emotions out.
You've got to let your emotions out.
You've got,
if you've got to cry,
cry.
If you and I understand where that's coming from,
and you can get to a point as a person,
if there's something that's really traumatic that's happening and all you do is
hold it in,
and I've seen guys get destroyed over that because they're not expressing the
emotions that they have.
Right.
Okay.
But that's
at a big level,
right?
At a daily level.
No,
you don't express those things.
You keep them in Charlotte.
That's why I say it like that.
Like a big kind of sarcastic,
but I'm being serious.
Yeah.
You know?
It's just don't let your emotions out and into the world.
Keep them for yourself.
Own them.
Don't share them with other people.
If you don't have to.
Yeah.
Now again,
people are gonna Freak out that I'm saying this because Barry,
your emotions because then what happens when you bury your,
when you've got something really traumatic that you bury,
then in each you apart,
and I've talked about that.
I mean talking about things that you go through in life and,
and expressing those feelings that you have met them,
that's good.
But what we're talking about is not that what we're talking about,
his daily emotions,
little ups and downs,
little tick marks on your Richter scale.
We're not talking about an 8.8 on the Richter scale,
right?
We're talking about just like little twos.
And when you express those twos and threes on the Richter scale out to people,
you just look unstable.
Hangry.
That's a two.
Yeah.
Overall,
and I'm not to split hairs are nothing,
but overall it's,
it's more about dealing with your quote unquote.
So yeah,
if you,
if a good conducive way to deal with your emotions is to let them out.
And there's all different kinds of emotions.
Like if you're sad,
if something's eating you up on the inside because of sadness or whatever and
it's conducive to your recovery development,
whatever,
to express those emotions,
then yes,
but if you're hangry and you lose your temper on your kid,
that's not going to,
you're not dealing with your emotions correctly,
so in stripe emotion,
but it's not really,
it is stifling them,
but before you stifle them,
you're identifying them.
You're like,
oh,
hey,
I'm hangry.
Okay.
I identified that I'm going to separate feelings from behavior that's dealing
with your emotions right there,
that's dealing with,
it's a great point that oftentimes expressing your emotions to the world doesn't
improve your situation or your position.
Not all.
Correct.
In fact,
I would say that most of the time,
expressing your emotions to the world sets you back,
and that is why I vote.
In many cases,
stifle your emotions.
Keep them in.
Don't let other people see you.
Put your cards on the table,
right?
You put your emotional cards on the table.
Now you can't gamble anymore.
You can't.
You're not in the game anymore.
The person knows what's going on.
You're giving it to them,
you're not gonna know what I'm thinking.
You're going to think I'm just,
everything's cool with me were trainings you did too,
right?
If I'm getting frustrated and I show that to you,
what does that do?
You're getting all of a sudden you,
you just go level up.
You Think,
oh,
I gotta be,
he's frustrated.
I can't,
oh,
I'm working.
This is working against them.
If I'm just saying the same face all the time,
which is what I do primarily,
hey,
same face all the time.
Just we're,
you know,
moving the same way.
When you do get me,
I forget what you say when you get me to react to something good.
Recognize the urgency.
You say you recognize a little urgency there and I always go down.
I don't want him to recognize,
I'd rather just have you just pass my guard and you're just there and we just
sit there like it's no big deal.
Not In me.
Get all panicky where then you level up a little bit.
And that's the same thing with life,
right?
Every time you express these big emotions to your boss or to your team,
you express these big emotions to your team.
They see all your cards.
Don't let them see all your cards.
Is this manipulating kind of,
right?
This is one of those things where people think,
oh,
transparency.
We hear that all the time.
These days.
Transparency.
You've got to be transparent.
No,
actually you don't.
Yeah know with that,
you don't have to be transparent all the time.
You have to win the game.
You know what?
Does the football coach go out and canvass playbook to the other football team?
No.
He's got to win the game.
Typically.
No,
and that's not how you win the game.
So are we.
You know what we're doing?
We're playing chess.
It's emotional chest.
You're playing with other human beings.
You want to win.
Now if you're winning so that I can take advantage of you so I can manipulate
you and get something from you that you don't want to give me.
That's bad.
And I'm not talking about doing that.
But if one of them doing is keeping my calm so that instead of escalating an
argument with you,
I'm getting you to see it from my perspective just by remaining calm.
That's what we're talking about here.
And you'll leave told that story the other day where it,
he tells the story lot cause it was hilarious story where I came in,
we didn't have a chance to talk to each other.
I,
he was playing in this big operation and I come in 10 minutes before the
operation,
I said,
hey,
let me,
let me see what you're doing.
And he kind of shows me on a map,
hey,
we're going to go here,
here and here.
I was like,
Hey,
you should do this instead.
And he was like,
do we leave it in 10 minutes?
And I said,
man,
but just think about it.
And he goes,
you know what,
just cancel the OP.
And he was all mad.
Right.
And,
and you know,
he's,
he's like an Jocko kind of like laughed at me.
I did laugh at him like a leg,
like a jerk,
you know?
It was like nobody,
I was like,
hey man,
listen,
just think about what I'm saying right now.
But that's the,
that's an example,
right?
I didn't show my emotions,
which was,
which would be more like,
dude,
are you serious right now?
You're going to cancel an op because we have a difference of opinion and think
about what your,
I didn't do that.
I was like,
hey man,
I get it.
Everyone's stressed out right now.
We've got to leave on this thing quickly.
Think about what I'm saying.
They'll look at it.
This is all I'm saying.
We could execute this in a better way.
So that's what I'm talking about.
Does that make me manipulative?
No,
it doesn't make me manipulative.
It makes us as a team do a better job.
And as soon as life saw that and he was like deescalated himself and he was good
to go,
we we move on.
Yeah.
So that's what I'm talking about.
Stifle your emotions at all times,
you know?
And,
and just to address that though,
for Real,
when you do see the big emotional impactful things in someone's life and they
don't express them,
that absolutely is bad.
And I'll tell you where you see this a lot is with kids,
you know,
kids,
teens where they,
they there something bothering them and they don't,
they hold it in,
hold it in because they don't have anybody to talk to.
They can't talk to mom and dad because mom and dad don't get it.
Their friends are the people that they're pissed off and pissed off at anyways,
so they can't tell them what's going on.
So they sit there and they harbor a lot of that anger and that can be,
that can be very problematic.
And it goes through all through,
you know,
adults as well.
And,
and you know,
at work sometimes people,
they got problems at home so they can't talk to their wife because that's what
the problem was.
And they can't talk to her husband because that's the source of the problem.
But then they get to work and they don't want to look like the person that's got
problems at home.
So I'm not going to say anything there either.
And the next thing you do,
what are they doing?
They're trying to escape those problems.
How are they doing it?
Instead of,
instead of letting those problems out and talking to somebody about them,
they're having a,
you know,
having a drink in the afternoon,
getting on the alcohol,
whatever.
They're doing something that's negative and they're not moving forward at all.
So those are not the kind of feelings that,
and emotions that you want to subdue or stifle.
But these little ones,
twos and threes on the Richter scale being hangry,
get,
control those things and stifling,
stifling certain emotions ones and twos is a good way to deal with them because
when these,
cause they're usually real spontaneous emotions.
They'll and they'll,
they don't have the power to sustain.
Yes,
they're just gonna they're there and then they just fade away and that's cool.
That's why.
Yes,
correct.
Then over time,
now you're good at dealing with them in that way.
When you get hangry and you've been for one year,
you've been dealing with it by just ignoring it,
you know,
in regards to behavior,
just not acting on it.
Now you're good at doing that,
and that's automatic.
Now you don't get,
you don't act hangry anymore.